tu gagnes et tu te rends compte
aujourd'hui il sait quoi
ma petite fille les beaux sauts à son
fait
wright il faut par pays arabes et à
l'armée belge est en train de
réorganiser à paris je sais qu'ils
cherchent et volontaire
papa doit leur donner une bonne raclée à
ses poches sur leur facebook
juge que pour deux semaines écoute ce
que je te dis les gens tu vas voir que
la guerre sera finie en un rien de temps
banny français c'est mon neveu
open pas trop tout est vieux temps en
temps ils nous ont gazés
pas bien à porto non ça va pas bien du
tout
feraient mieux d'essayer de penser aux
autres lui retirer la tête et nous
emmerder tous les jours avec la mimi à
led et violet way et l'or contre la
russie a été violée je vous embête avec
montceau en ou non on l'a tous le
souvenir